una investigación de la fiscalía sueca
da indicios sobre un presunto Sabotaje
contra el nordstream la pesquisa en la
que participan Suecia Dinamarca y
Alemania tras excluir a Rusia hayó
restos de explosivos en el mar Báltico
donde el 26 de septiembre estallaron los
gasoductos nordstream 1 y 2 en las
investigaciones que se hicieron en el
lugar en el mar Báltico se incautaron
muchos objetos y el área está
documentada de forma minuciosa los
análisis realizados muestran restos de
explosivos en varios de los objetos
encontrados el trabajo de análisis
avanzado continúa para poder sacar
conclusiones más seguras sobre el
incidente Los investigadores no han
señalado los autores del ataque hay
consenso en que edad a su magnitud el
plan requirió los recursos de un actor
Estatal de sus servicios de inteligencia
o de su ejército el bando atlantista
insinúa sin verbalizarlo un ataque ruso
para desestabilizar a Bruselas por otro
lado Rusia acusa abiertamente a Reino
Unido del ataque
supuestamente coordinado con Estados
Unidos que siempre se opuso a la
construcción de la infraestructura una
acusación que Londres rechaza de acuerdo
con la información disponible
representantes De esta unidad de la
marina británica participaron en el plan
en el apoyo y en la ejecución de este
ataque terrorista en el mar Báltico del
26 de septiembre de este año al explotar
los gaseoductos nordstream 1 y nordstrom
2 un gran golpe de efecto sin
consecuencias en el suministro de gas
Europa
las explosiones reventaron las dos
tuberías del North tribuno que no
bombeaba gas desde agosto y una tubería
del nordstream 2 que nunca llegó a
operar bloqueado por Alemania la otra
tubería del northream 2 permanece
inoperativa pero intacta un último
vínculo de la gran conexión energética
entre Rusia y la Unión Europea